celui qui a mis les pieds à moscou après
les années 2000 c'est très bien que la
scène gastronomique russe est très
appétissante et l'arrivée du guide
michelin dans la capitale russe n'a fait
que le confirmer pour un gourmand avisé
moscou vaut absolument le détour david
eberlé chef français du restaurant
grands crus fait partie des sept chefs
d'établissement moscovite ayant décroché
une étoile au michelin s'appuyant sur sa
grosse expérience dans des restaurants
étoilés icaunais mouscou depuis une
vingtaine d'années à ses yeux le
véritable essor de la cuisine russe date
de 2014 et des sanctions alimentaire que
la russie a imposé en réponse aux
sanctions occidentales après 2014 on a
commencé à travailler des produits
locaux il ya dix ans il n'y avait pas de
saint-jacques russe à moscou et puis
maintenant on en a partout de sakhaline
donc il ya eu je pense que maintenant
c'est mieux léa les russes qui ont pris
les choses en main et puis qui ont
commencé à voile à écrire un peu leur
leur tendance avec les idées les idées
européennes nordiques et c'est un
asiatique un peu de mélange et tout et
puis voilà il pris malgré les crises
moscou continue de d'évoluer de
progresser donc non je pense qu'ils
arrivent au bon moment le destin fait
bien les choses le maire à develop puis
à moscou cc rénové depuis ces vingt
dernières années quand même donc
maintenant on est prêt à recevoir toute
cette clientèle
en national et national mais qui
arrivent de toute la russie pour
découvrir la gastronomie et la
gastronomie la culture à moscou la
chefferie que thierry nallo fina est
persuadé que le guide michelin ne va pas
s'arrêter à mouscou et qui va explorer
d'autres virus
seule femme de la sélection et et erin
alphinat est propriétaire de son propre
établissement est logique et là était
également décoré d'une étoile verte
michelin pour son approche durable mais
aussi sa conception zéro déchet
m'appelle on commence
tout d'abord nous avons un grand pays un
pays intéressant et beaucoup d'étrangers
pense que la cuisine russe se limite à
la cuisine soviétique avec de la
mayonnaise de la salade le hareng son
saphir le banc et ainsi de suite
allez y et ses façons de bourse et
l'autre aux tablettes samedi
24 à dire c'est en réalité nous avons de
grandes traditions passe notamment en
matière de fermentation sein ce que chez
nous l'hiver est long et pour l'hiver
nos ancêtres faisait des salaisons de
plantes de champignons il m'arrivait et
faisait sécher de la viande
quant aux jumeaux berezutski y constate
qu'un bouleversement est à l'oeuvre mais
si ces derniers temps car les russes se
rendent compte qu'ils ont eux aussi des
produits de très grande qualité sur leur
sol et ont donc cessé de vénérer tout ce
qui vient de l'étranger le restaurant
des deux frères le twist garden est l'un
des deux établissements de la capitale
avoir reçu deux étoiles michelin
le monde s'intéresse à la cuisine russe
pour le moment bien sûr elle n'est pas
aussi bien promues que par exemple la
cuisine italienne mais comme dit le
proverbe russe on met du temps pour
atteler mais on prend de la vitesse
après
et donc vous savez il y a un intérêt
pour la cuisine russe et on associe
quand même l'arrivée du guide michelin
justement à cet intérêt pour la cuisine
russe pour les traditions russes pour
les produits alimentaires russe
cela va-t-il changer c'est déjà en train
de changer vous savez ça avait déjà
commencé avant je crois que l'arrivée du
guide michelin est une conséquence de
l'intérêt pour la cuisine russe pour les
restaurants russe cela a donné une
grande impulsion au développement
la pandémie de colis de 19 à largement
restreint les itinéraires touristiques
mais une fois cette plaie refermer
moscou sera prête à accueillir de
nouveaux les voyageurs internationaux et
pas seulement avec le boersch et les
blemmyes